john lynch first ran for governor of new
hampshire
when i was 15. he was then in office
until i was 23
which means i've been exposed to
politics for a significant part of my
life
in fact i think i was in about 63
parades
all over new hampshire campaigning for
my dad
aside from my dad i've always enjoyed
reading about the candidates
and being somewhat involved with the
campaigns
but this year felt different
this year i felt i needed to take a more
active role
by volunteering with the guiding
campaign
this year i knew i had to use my voice
to reach out to everyone in my network
and beyond to encourage people
to get involved and to vote
this year is different because i don't
want to wake up the morning of november
4th
and ask myself what else could i have
done
as a survivor of domestic violence and
sexual assault
i want a president who i trust will
fight for survivors
and put right protections in place
with more than one in three women
being subjected to physical violence
rape
and or stalking by a partner at some
point
in their lives i want a president
who is willing to change this statistic
and protect women who stand up to their
abusers
joe and jill biden have fought for women
for decades
and will continue this fight to protect
women
and end once and for all gender-based
violence
as someone who's had to navigate the
health care system as a patient
and who works in the health care
industry i
understand how difficult it is
i want a president who's going to fight
to help make health care
more accessible more affordable
and focused on the patient
i can't imagine the single mother
working
three jobs taking care of her kids
taking care of her aging parents
and having to navigate the health care
system
and pay for prescriptions with no
insurance
this is not right it's not fair
joe biden has a plan he has already laid
out
to protect and expand upon the aca
and ensure every american has health
care coverage
increasing health care access is
important to me
it's important for men for women for
kids
and for all granite staters
as a woman who is thinking of starting a
family
i want to feel like i can bring a child
into a safe world
where everyone is respected and loved
by our president as dr biden knows
firsthand
post-secondary education changes lives
and i want my kids to be able to afford
to go to college
and they deserve to live in a world
where we are
actively fighting climate change and
trying to make the world
a better place i know
joe biden is this president
he will fight for all these things and
so much more
vice president joe biden dr jill biden
and senator kamala harris will listen to
the american people
to the granite staters to women
and fight for each and every one of us
together they will help build back
better
and set the country up to be better for
our generation
our kids generation and our
grandchildren's generation
these are some of the reasons behind my
energy
and courage to reach out to people in my
network
and beyond and ask what
is your plan to vote how can i help you
make a plan
on the days where i get nervous to
message this person i haven't spoken to
in years
i remind myself that this election is
bigger than me
and the potential to increase one more
vote for biden
is worth the embarrassment i might feel
for that person not responding
and on my weakest days
i think of rbg and how much
i want to continue rbg's legacy
i have used my voice to message people
through text
instagram facebook emails
calls and i've even shown up to family
brunches with
applications for absentee ballots
complete with addressed envelopes and
stamps
i basically give people zero excuses to
not vote
and make it extremely easy for them
for the people who say i'm gonna sit
this election out
i ask why let's discuss
my dad used to always say we
live in the greatest state in the
greatest country
in the world i believe this is true
but i think there's a lot of work that
needs to be done
to recover from the last four years
this is why i'm supporting joe biden and
kamala harris
and this is why i'm fighting every day
to get them elected
i now have the honor and privilege to
introduce to you
ann ketterer the new hampshire
democratic party women's caucus co-chair
thank you
thank you julia and um
thank you all for being here looking out
among you all it's nice to see so many
faces or at least
half your faces um i actually see a
beautiful patchwork of many different
colors of masks and i like it
i want to say a special thank you to the
party for organizing
this event um it's not easy to get this
done in a way that is safe
so that we all feel secure about our
health but it's so meaningful
to me to be here with all of you amazing
women
in person it means a great deal so thank
you to the party for helping with this
event
so i'm here today really to talk about
women and i'm going to start with myself
so in 2016
i was opinionated and i was informed and
i was a voter
four years later i'm still opinionated
i'm still informed and yes of course i
vote
the difference is that now i'm an
activist
because i like so many women probably so
many of you
woke up the day after the election
and thought what happened and what can i
do about it
women rose up
showed our force our numbers
in the women's march the day after the
inauguration
women drove the change of the blue wave
in 2018.
women who'd never voted before suddenly
started knocking on doors
women who'd never run for public office
before ran for public office
women stood up got to work
and made a change in that election and
will make a change in the following
elections because that's the next
generation of leadership in america
the truth is this is nothing new
for women for millennia we have had to
fight for our dignity
in this world so let's take a minute
and talk about women we're awesome
that's true
okay give ourselves a round of applause
yeah
but we're also organized and we're
determined and resilient
and we're fearless think about 100 years
ago
think about the progress we've made in a
hundred years the progress from our
grandmothers and our mothers the things
that their organization
their determination has earned us the
right to vote
the right to open up a bank account
without your husband's name on it
the right to start a family when and how
we choose and the right
to pursue a career in even male
dominated professions
personally i'm an architect and when i
was a little kid
my mom said ann what do you want to be
when you grow up and i said mommy i want
to be an architect
and she said yes you can do that you can
do anything that you
want she said anne when i was growing up
and and trust me i love my grandparents
they were wonderful people
they didn't mean anything poorly by this
statement but
it was a sign of the times her parents
said to her
janice what'll it be
do you want to be a teacher or a
secretary
and she became a teacher
and that was a wonderful profession but
she said anne you can be a teacher too
if you want but you can be anything
you want to be because it's through this
grit
that we've afforded this for ourselves
and it just never ends and as i look
out at all of you today
i'm confident that each and every one of
you at some point in your life
has exceeded expectations has defied
the norm whether it's your professional
life your
your political life your academic life
your personal life
i guarantee you've all done that and
that's what we're going to keep doing
this election is critical and we need to
be
fearless what does that mean that means
we're going to keep doing what we
started doing the day after
the 2016 election we're gonna make phone
calls we're gonna text
we can't knock on doors but we can
encourage people to vote we're gonna
make a plan
donate if we can but i'm here to ask you
to charge to you call your friends
call your loved ones call your neighbors
call your co-workers call people that
you think
are undecided or maybe they voted for
trump last time because because why not
call them and ask them
talk to them about covid19
about what the last six months of our
lives
of what your life in this pandemic has
been like
your mental health your 401k
your job security your kids education
talk to them
talk to them about healthcare what
healthcare means to you and your family
and talk to them about civility because
i remember a time
when the tone in washington was
different and women
we are fearless we can do this we're
going to have the awkward conversations
we're going to get out the vote and just
as we have always done we're going to
create this change
and women it's not
the supreme court of the united states
that's going to make joe biden our next
president
it's us
and i'm excited to present the next
speaker
my friend and neighbor the president of
new hampshire
young democrats miss ashley marku an
impressive woman
good afternoon ladies my name is
an organization whose mission is to
recruit train and elect
the next generation of young leaders
here in new hampshire
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak with you today
to anne and julia for sharing your
stories and to dr biden
for bringing this incredible dedicated
group of women together
just 32 days before we elect joe biden
kamala harris to begin the hard work of
healing our nation
from the pandemic and the presidency
that has been donald trump's
we've all heard a few times now that our
lives are on the ballot this year
and we didn't need the tragic loss of
200 000 american lives to tell us that
every election people live and die by
the policies passed by those
who win vote for our lives
our dignity in our future but now more
than ever
after the tragic passing of the late
justice uh
ruth bader ginsburg we must vote for our
women their dignity and their futures
when i was growing up my parents told me
and i don't like dance
that i could be anything that i wanted
to be my mother was open with me
about where babies came from and i knew
that contraception would be available to
me
when i was ready to seek it out they
taught me that parenthood is the most
joyful burden of love there is but it
comes with a great responsibility
and i knew that my dreams and my body
and my choices
would be respected just like every human
should be
but most of all i knew that i had
choices and that no person would be able
to take them away from me
i'm scared for girls growing up today
who may not have those choices
donald trump made his respect for women
clear before he was even our president
between treating his daughter like an
object to where he grabs women when he
thinks no one is listening
it's clear that he has none and that he
spent his presidency
attempting to strip women of their
autonomy dignity and equal rights
but we will not go back here in new
hampshire and together we will vote
it's easy and convenient to vote this
year you can vote by mail
in person at your local clerk's office
or head to the polls on election day
but grab your mask however you choose
you have to have a plan to make sure
that your voice is heard
you have to have a plan to elect joe
biden and kamala harris
who will protect and celebrate the
rights of women in the progress that
we've made instead of doing everything
in their power to try to tear it down
this election is just too important to
set out so stand up
make a plan to elect joe biden who will
be a president
that will ensure that our daughters and
sons have the choices
dignity and rights that they deserve
thank you
[Music]
i wish we followed your actions
good afternoon everyone i am the
honorable and i say that with such love
and grace and joy and peace
as a public servant like so many of you
today
i'd like to make a couple of remarks
that the campaign
suggested we are praying for a safe
recovery
for the trumps since the start of covet
19
the campaign's top priority has been the
health
of voters across the country the biden
campaign
has been working closely with public
health experts
to determine the best practices for
campaign
safety they will continue to campaign
with public health
as our top priority the bidens and the
traveling staff
have been regularly tested and committed
to making
a positive test result public
after tuesday's debate the campaign is
taking
extra precautions to make sure vice
president biden
dr jill biden and all the travelers
are safe
now i'd like to begin my remarks
you know we are new hampshire and we are
first
and we are the granite state and we are
working
women and as you all know that
if i wasn't in the house some days i was
at the pa library
and other days i was at the gap because
that's what women do
and men do when you have four kids and
you want to put your kids through
college
you get another job and it's such an
honor to be here today
with dr jill biden the last time i saw
dr jill
please check it out today she does not
have them on
she has these gorgeous high heel boots
that
are engraved on the side vote
so whenever you see a picture of her
next time
look for those boots that say vote
they're for more than walking
together we are joining a movement which
was started over a century ago
by the suffragettes and activists who
fought for our right as women
to have our voices heard and i know some
of you saw the american experience film
on the vote and you saw a number of
women
who worked very very hard but as you
know
it took many many years to get the right
to vote
and i stand here standing in the shoes
of my sisters
gladly and today
100 years after new hampshire ratified
the 19th amendment together we make up
the movement that's going to win this
election
and change our country forever
yesterday at the united nations we
celebrated the 25th anniversary
of the beijing conference
as our low beloved speaker terry norelli
myself and 12 others were in beijing
at that time terry and i both decided
that when we returned home
we would run for office but more than
that we wanted to share
that experience and our wonderful
governor
jeanne shaheen and it was the first and
the last time
that 500 women took over the state house
and we brought back beijing
the women who were there committed
themselves
to running for public office themselves
i myself decided to go under the
tutelage
of our state senator was retired this
year
martha fuller clark for martha
i thank her for her mentorship for all
of these years she sat down with me
in the basement of the state house
to get legislation through and the first
bill that we did
was this uh sea door bill the convention
to eliminate
all forms of discrimination against
women for martha to teach me how to be a
legislature
i will never forget i didn't get a
chance to see martha
when she was coming in but i hope my
words and greeting
and love and respect say so much martha
can you please stand up
[Applause]
as we said we have an opportunity this
election
to elect the first woman and the first
woman of color
to be vice president of the united
states
now when we were on a zoom call as we
all know that word zoom
i was working with some of her sorrow
sisters her sorority sisters
and the woman out of south carolina that
senator emily levesque and i met many
years ago
they are still working so i decided this
election to do
a different tact i began working with
black women
for bibi because we felt that again
over 100 years later we knew we had to
mobilize
every single person in the united states
and the black women and the women of
color you may not see us
but we're calling the brothers we're
calling our nephews
we're calling all of the men every week
there is a video and a talk called
shop talk we're hitting the barber shops
we're heading
the beauty parlors we're hitting the
hair places
folks are out in harlem and all over the
city
working for biden
[Applause]
we also have an opportunity to return dr
jill biden to the white house
many years ago and i'm joanne dowdell is
not here
but dr jill biden invited a number of us
from around the country to blair house
why was she an entertainer it wasn't the
food
it wasn't the drinks it was her care and
love
of asking each one of us how are you
doing
what's going on in your life and we had
a good time
for that time i will never forget her
love and hospitality
thank you again dr chuck
as we know dr jill is also a champion
for education
and i love it she's at community
colleges because as we all know
sometimes going to a four-year college
it's not the right fit right away
some of us you just weren't mature
enough
but that two-year college made up for
everything you weren't doing
in high school but it also gave you that
sense
of who you are as a person and for
what she did as a champion for military
and veteran families for health care
and for the fight of cancer because she
worked on breast cancer
as i recall so thank you so very much
but to get there we have work to do so
at this point i need you all to stand up
because you need to stand up ladies
everybody stand up
okay now where i come from you got to
plant your feet on the ground i changed
out of my high heels and put on my flex
so we have about five times that you're
going to say the words
not on our watch so here it goes
because donald trump's not going to go
easily
not on my watch can you all say that not
on our watch
donald trump wants four main years of
moving backwards
not on our watch donald trump wants to
strip health care from
a hundred thousand granite staters what
do we say
not on our watch donald trump wants an
economy that penalizes women
for wanting a career and a family what
do we say
and as we've seen with the supreme court
nomination
a country where women aren't free to
make decisions about their own bodies
what do we say
for four years donald trump has shown
he's not willing to put in the work
to lift working women up and we know
we're cooking more
because we can't go to restaurants so
what do we say
not on our watch thank you very much
let's have a seat
biden has spent his career as an
advocate of gender equality
as the author of the violence against
women act
a proponent of the lilly ledbetter fair
pay act
in the obama administration
and i know i look young but i remember
when i got my first credit card it had
to be
in the name of my husband and you all
know how
i love russell but i wanted my own
credit card
and thanks to dr ruth bader genzer
ginsburg we now credit cards in our own
name
and today joe biden's the gender for
women's
envision a country where we finally give
up the higher ideal
that all men and all women are created
equal
so i wanted to say i asked it was this
plan where did joe say this
he has his plan called build back better
a woman who has worked
violence against women creating a 21st
century caregiving
a plan to vote if you don't do
anything today you will go to
iwillvote.com
now i know and we're talking about home
there are a lot of young people here for
the first time working on these
campaigns
and i have this wonderful woman rachel
just got out of college
we have to help these young people we
have to prepare
the next generation and rachel is one of
them
so if you do not know who your local
coordinator
is oh rachel she'll tell you who
everyone
is in the state give the campaigns at
least
five minutes now you know we've made
calls we hate getting hang up all hung
up on
because we've done it for so many years
joe has created something new
it's called vote joe and i love vote joe
let me tell you what vote joe is it's in
your cell phone
if you text five people that is equal
one hour of calling i was like
you mean i could just text five people i
know
and that means i don't have to get hung
up on for an hour
they said yes jackie you can so i sit
there in front of the zoom and go
folks we can do this we can use this new
technology
and this is what's so wonderful about
this campaign
joe and these young people have upped
this campaign
to put us in the 21st century
it's hard for some of us i now wear blue
glasses
because i'm on zoom so much get some
staples it's work
so we will make a plan today can we all
come in it and say
yes we will
we can make the difference in this
election to put joe and jill
and my girl kamelo and doug we
all love doug in the white house
thank you so very much it's been an
honor
and i'd love to
may 12 i was seven months pregnant
yes i didn't know anything
canvassing which was as you can imagine
seven eight months pregnant
miserable at times
selection and i absolutely refuse to sit
on the sidelines
years from now i refuse to look at my
kids and their eyes
and say to them i did nothing i can't
live with that
and this is why i volunteer there are
many issues that i hold dear to my heart
some of them being climate change having
lived on the coast
i've seen first hand the devastation
that hurricanes can have on communities
particularly those of color and
low-income areas
equality for the lgbtq and community is
also a very important
issue for me ending gun violence
no parent should fear their child going
to school
and being in harm's way no parent should
have to
grief a child losing their life in the
streets
or at the hands of a police officer
education health care immigration
coveted 19 and the reopening of our
schools for our children
systemic racism all of these things are
on the ballot
and they could not be more important and
then there's women's rights
which i know is much of our focus today
i want my daughter riley
to grow up in a society where she gets
equal pay for the same work as men
where she can make her own decisions
about her body regarding health care
and i don't want her to have to decide
between starting a family and continuing
with her career
and i know that biden has a plan for
these things so that she will have those
opportunities in the future
but with all of these issues for the
last four years
donald trump has failed us and
especially now in this pandemic with
covid
after millions of americans have lost
their jobs from a mismanaged economic
recession
including thousands of granite staters
200
000 americans have died and that number
is climbing each and every day
and more than 430 of them right here in
new hampshire
president trump refuses to listen to the
scientists and the experts
and to address the severity of this
virus so it's clear
there's no rock bottom that donald trump
would be faced with that would change
his ways when we feel like our voices
don't matter or that our system is
broken
trump wins but americans are waking up
and rejecting his division and women
women are the ones leading the charge
i'm here today for my kids my daughter
riley and my son reese
who i want to grow up with a president
and first lady they can look up to
as a role model not who not one who
mocks a disabled reporter or who mocks
greitenberg an environmental activist
and a child
who has asperger's a president who
disrespects our veterans
women and who unequivocally refuses to
condemn white supremacists at the very
first
opportunity to do so
i'm here for the first female vice
president and one of color
which will show my daughter riley that
any woman in america can do anything she
wants to that she can be anything in
this world
i'm here today also because the steps
that we take now
even after four years of chaos can pull
us back towards the country i know and
love dearly
and as joe often says we can finally
start to restore the soul of our nation
and as he also says here's the deal for
the future of our country for our
children
we need to elect joe biden and kamala
harris and vote democrats up and down
the ballot
and to do all these things and more we
need to vote
so critically important and we need to
vote like our lives depend on it because
they do
you need to contact friends and family
you can do that when you leave this
event today
ask them what their plans are to vote
are they going to vote via absentee are
they going to go
vote early go there in person sign up
for a local online phone bank
or texting as jackie had mentioned it
really is a lot of fun
bring a friend it doesn't have to be all
or nothing
the organizers that i've worked with
have been incredibly inspiring
and so helpful and even if you can do an
hour here or there every bit of that
time makes a difference
so please whatever you do today make a
plan to vote right now
to elect joe biden and kamala harris
because our country's future depends
on us next it is such an incredible
honor
for me to introduce our next speaker dr
jill biden is a community college
professor
and new york times best-selling author
she's been an educator for three decades
she earned her doctorate of education
from the university of delaware
and has two master's degrees both of
which she earned while working
and raising a family us women really can
do it all
she served the second lady of the united
states from 2009 to 2017
and during the obama biden
administration she advocated for
military families
community colleges and the fight against
cancer and the education of women and
girls around the entire world
today she continues her work teaching
english at northern virginia community
college
and is traveling the nation to help
elect her husband vice president joe
biden
to the presidency of the united states
so it is with tremendous honor to
introduce the next first lady
of the united states dr jill biden
thank you
thank you
thanks
thank you courtney and uh thank you
riley for joining us today and
uh i know that time is precious
and that's especially true when you're a
mom of a
seven-year-old and a four-year-old in
this time of the pandemic
still you make time to work for the
causes that you care about
at like protecting our environment and
uh
for for kids like riley and electing the
kind of leaders that we need
so we're grateful to have you on our
team both of you
and riley showed me she can do something
that no one else in this room can do
what do you think riley you want to show
them
wait come over here riley come over here
and show them
you guys won't you will not believe this
okay ready all right
go ahead
pretty spectacular right anybody want to
try it
[Laughter]
so jackie and donna you know thank you
for
joining us both as well for joining us
and um
jackie i'm sorry i didn't wear my boat
boots i left them at home because um
i had to bring other boots because i'm
going oyster
shucking is that what you call it later
you know after i leave here so i had to
wear my
like real high boots to go wade in the
water and get oysters
but anyway uh jackie and donna
have both been really effective leaders
here in new hampshire
you know when i first met donna we sat
for what like two hours and discussed
everything but politics i think we would
talk books and clothes and
you know just everything so we instantly
hit it off as friends so um donna thank
you so much for your friendship
and uh we'll have to talk books after
this
so let me start by uh sending my
thoughts
and prayers for the health and safety of
the president
and the first lady after they tested
positive
uh for cobot 19. and joe and i pray that
they will quickly recover
and make a full recovery and
that's this is just not a matter of
politics it's a
a matter of health and respect
so it's great to be back in manchester
and over these last few months i've been
talking to uh communities
about school reopenings which you might
imagine since i'm a teacher
and a few weeks ago i spoke to a public
school counselor
who told me something that she won't
forget
and she said you know the two
important roles in my life
are being a school counselor and a mom
and right now i feel like i'm failing
at both as a parent
you always want to have answers for your
kids
right i mean that's what we do but these
last four years
you know so many parents have told me
that they
really have more questions than
answers for instance like how do i keep
my family
safe during this pandemic you know what
happens
if god forbid a school shooting happens
at our schools
what if i lose my job which i'm sure is
on the minds of many of you
right now today and how do i tell my
kids
to be kind when our leaders
don't live up to that same standard
and it's not just parents it's
all of us you know we all feel it the
chaos
of this moment and the magnitude of
all the loss that surrounds us right now
still we keep going don't we
you know we keep helping our neighbors
and
showing up for each other we keep
hoping for the better
what else can we do you know joe and i
know that feeling well
four days after our sun beau's funeral
i watched joe shade put on his suit
and i saw him steal himself in the
mirror
take a breath put his shoulders back
and walk into a world
empty of our son
he went back to work that's
just who he is and i
could not imagine how he did it
how he put one foot in front of the
other
and kept going but i've always
understood why he did it
he did it for the daughter who pays for
the mom's
breast cancer screening and misses
work to drive her mom to the clinic
for the community college student who's
faced
homelessness and survived abuse but
finds the grit to keep going and get her
degree
for the little boy whose mom is serving
in iraq as a marine who puts on this
brave face when he gets on that video
call
when all he wants is
you know is to see her just see her
and be with her for his birthday
he does it for you he
does it for us joe
has spent his entire career
listening to people and bringing people
together
he will be a president for
all americans
and he has a plan for all americans
to end this pandemic
to rebuild to reimagine a future that's
better than ever but he can't do it
without you over these last few years
joe has faced unimaginable
tragedies and through it all
he learned how to heal a broken
family it's the same way
that you heal a nation
love and understanding and with small
acts of kindness
with bravery with unwavering
faith right now there are so
many who want to tell us that our nation
is hopelessly divided
that our differences are irreconcilable
that our communities are fractured
beyond repair
and beneath that is another message your
voice can't fix it
your vote doesn't matter but that's not
who we are is it manchester
in this pandemic we
are coming together and holding on to
each other
[Applause]
we're finding mercy and grace in the
moments that we may have
once taken for granted we're seeing that
our
differences are precious and that our
similarities
are infinite democrat and republican
urban and rural north
and south coast the coast our
communities are
showing that the heart of this nation
still beats with kindness
and courage
we don't agree on everything we don't
have to
we can still love and respect one
another
can't we we care more about people
than politics and we know we're not
broken
we're becoming something new cynics
play to our fears they tell us that we
can't make a difference because they
don't want us to try
they know that together our voices are
more powerful than they ever could be
we have to show them our power
especially women because
women take care of our communities
we know how to organize and we know how
to win
elections
i can see you're ready
this is our moment we have to show them
that we're not gonna sit by and
watch what happens we're gonna take
control
and decide what happens
here in new hampshire ballots are
available
right now so make a plan by going to
iwillboat.com
and help your family and your friends
make a plan to vote
and then get involved i know you're
like swamped with stuff to do you know i
know you're tired and you're stretched
thin
but this is too important to sit it out
so you have to do we have to do
everything we can
so text join to 30330
to find out ways to volunteer but i'm
sure you know
i'm sure you're all doing this already i
know who you are
so this is it there are no
do-overs in this election
we have to believe that our communities
are
stronger than the challenges they face
because they are we have to believe
that our votes matter because they do
we have to show up right now put our
shoulders back
and work like we have never worked
before
will you join us will you help show
our nation that we will never settle for
less than our highest aspirations
stand with joe biden and kamala harris
because when you do i know we will win
so i want to end i want to end by saying
thank you thank you for all you
do for your communities thank you for
working so
hard for our campaign your
campaign and finally
thank you for your faith in an idea
that's bigger than
any one of us and that is
we will build a better nation because
women we are going to do this together
thank you thank you for all you're doing
thank you
thanks
thank you
you